[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in mike florio pro football
talk live
co-host so you don't have to deal with
any of this stuff mike do you i like it
though i like listening to it i like it
i like green day
i can only imagine the things that are
available to maybe
sample at the green day exhibit at the
rock and roll hall of fame
well legally in ohio i don't know it
it was a nice exhibit i took pictures
just to let
people know that i did go to try to
learn a little bit more about uh green
day that's all
that's what we do in this business mike
like you got to get out you got to go
meet people go to camp
talk to coaches gms i mean this is what
we we have to do is
it is i'm just getting that memo 20
years later i stay in my cave as much as
i can i think people prefer it that way
all right you got the cowboys and the
steelers they get to start practice on
wednesday
more interesting team to you between
those two
well i'd say the cowboys because they
always are it's close though this year
with the steelers i don't know what
their mindset is i don't know why they
brought ben roethlisberger back i don't
know why he came back it doesn't feel
like they're going to be
as successful as last year that afc is
so
top-heavy with super bowl contenders
it's going to be a tough year for the
best teams in the afc for the cowboys
their path to the division championship
is wide open
they could win it easily they're favored
to win it although i don't think they
should be i think it should be
washington but with the dak prescott
injury which by all appearances is
healed ezekiel elliott can he get back
to being the guy he was a couple of
years ago can they
do anything defensively and it's the
cowboys and they're han hard knocks i
mean so the cowboys are always going to
be a team
even when it feels like that that star
is a little tarnished they still
are a team that everyone wants to pay
attention to why do the steelers bring
ben back
i think what happened sims and i talked
about this on pft live i think they had
enough time
after their loss to the browns in the
playoffs
and to process the way things fell apart
after
the steelers started 11-0 to convince
themselves
that we don't have to rebuild we just
have to reload
if we fix this and this and this and
this you get into kind of an
echo chamber with your front office and
your coaching staff and they convince
themselves they can make a run at the
super bowl and win it
and we're going to do it we're going to
bring him back we're going to have that
one more year and i think part of it too
was
they didn't know what else they were
going to do if they didn't bring back
ben roethlisberger they didn't draft
high enough
to get a a first-round talent that could
be the next franchise quarterback like
they did in 2004 when they had the 11th
pick so
i think that part of it was hubris and
part of it
is we don't know what plan b would be
so let's stick with with uh ben
rothsberg
yeah and i know they brought in haskins
uh i guess
just to see if there is potential there
but i
i mason rudolph is not threatening
anybody i don't know if they didn't see
a quarterback in the draft that they
could get
or was worth going to get may i don't
know if it was something as simplistic
as that and then you just thought all
right well
we can fall back on ben and ben did have
pretty good numbers those first what 11
games or so
but um and their receivers were
i think they had they dropped more balls
than any other receivers
so now you've added a running back um
i don't know what their style is going
to be but it'll be tough sledding
in that division one thing jerome bettis
told ed bouchet of the athletic last
year was the running game
is something that that begins in
training camp you have to have a
commitment up front
it's a different style of blocking and
you have to have a mindset that you were
going to
you were going to mash people who are
across from you and open up those holes
and they have huge turnover on the
offensive line
that's the big unknown with the steelers
this year
all the turnover on the offensive line
will the new players
be as good or better than the guys
they're replacing and
and and we'll see and dan i don't know
if you saw this or talked about it but
there was an item recently on a tell
that ben roethlisberger has when he's in
shotgun formation where when it's a pass
he's got his left heel off the ground
when it's a run he's flat-footed
defenses see that they know about that
and
if you know before the snap whether it's
a runner or a pass
that's 85 of the battle if they can iron
that out when you consider how good
their offense was even with that tell if
they can get rid of that
they could be a lot better potentially
on offense if you just take off the
table
hey defense we're running or we're
passing that could make a huge
difference
wait how does the tell get told
somebody studied the film and and and
noticed it somebody
studied the film and saw that the heels
off the ground when he passes
and he's flat-footed when he runs and i
don't know how long that's been the case
but it's a pretty basic yes no
pass run thing and if defensive players
are seeing it
before the snap that that that that
would explain
why they ran the ball so poorly last
year if
every time they ran the ball somebody up
front could see that ben was standing
flat-footed and that many was going to
hand it off out of shotgun
i remember rodney harrison telling me
that he would watch tony gonzalez line
up
and he said if he lined up and maybe it
was a foot
a foot out he knew he it was a pass play
and if he lined up a little closer to
the tackle it was going to be a run
like just something so small but that's
all you're looking for
like what is your tell we're talking to
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host with chris sims
monday through friday you can watch that
on peacock i'm fascinated with
the rams and chargers because i don't
want to set my
expectations up too high for the
chargers as i always do
and the rams i find really fascinating
here
uh which one are you more interested in
seeing this season well i'm more
interested in the chargers i think the
chargers
have a great deal of talent they they
hit a home run in hiring brandon staley
to be the head coach i think he's going
to be a great coach
the challenge for the chargers is to
avoid injuries and
you mentioned rodney harrison i've been
sitting next to him for the last decade
and he's got this uncanny ability
watching nine games at once to spot the
potentially serious knee injury and
he'll slap me and he'll say watch this
replay
and you know 95 out of 100 times the guy
just jumps up and he's good to go
teams out there know how to properly
get their guys flexible and the tr
everything about the training side of it
to get guys to a point where they can go
out and play and not suffer serious
injury i think some teams are better
than others
and one of the problems with the
charters when you just look at the the
recent history of injury injury injury
injury
i hope they've taken a broader look at
their processes and
try to figure out what they can do to
limit the injuries because that's what
knocks them off
every single year they get key guys
injured and it falls apart for the rams
hey they got to the final eight
with jared goff at quarterback and now
they have matthew stafford
and whether they can get back there i
mean this could be the great litmus test
for the struggles of matthew stafford's
career was it him
was it the lions we're going to find out
this year
uh the obligatory aaron rodgers update
mike
well look i think he's going to be there
and
i think he's not going to say anything
because next monday
mark murphy the ceo of the packers gets
to meet with fans
slash shareholders at the annual meeting
and they haven't had a chance to voice
their displeasure with the past several
months and they're going to do it and
murphy's going to bear the brunt of it
and i think rogers is keeping his mouth
shut right now in part because he
doesn't want to make it any easier next
monday
when mark murphy has to address the
shareholders who understandably are
upset because they're caught in the
middle of this
that's the one thing i don't like about
it the players are caught in the middle
of it
the fans are caught in the middle of it
i think aaron rodgers is going to show
up and frankly i think when he does show
up
that could be when the packers starting
with murphy begin to soften on this idea
of potentially trading him because i
think if we
injected sodium pentathol into the veins
of mark murphy he would admit
that he'd rather aaron rodgers not show
up
but what is the goal here of aaron
rodgers
oh he wants to play somewhere else i
mean he wants to stick it to the packers
he's upset with the fact that he spent
years
believing he was untouchable and in one
moment
without a heads up without the courtesy
of a phone call or a text message or
anything
he found out he's not untouchable
because they traded up
to draft a quarterback who ostensibly
will replace him and at one point
i think it was when he was talking to
kenny mayne he made the comment
that his season last year threw a wrench
into the plan he believes that they
wanted to go from jordan love to aaron
rodgers after one season
of jordan love on the bench and and i
think he's
he's trying to force that now and and i
really do think his best chance of
getting traded this year
is to show up and and hope
that the people at the top of the
organization say let's just
get rid of this distraction because it's
going to be a mess of a season
a non-stop question is it his last year
let's just be done with it now and move
forward wait
so before this season you think he'll be
traded
as opposed to after the season well i
know i think his best
chance of getting traded before the
season is to show up i think holding out
is not the way to get traded i think
he's got a better chance of getting
traded if he shows up
and it's this constant circus of is this
his last year have they promised to
trade him he's asked about it all the
time
he makes his little snide pass
aggressive comments so they have to
scour everything he says to see who he's
taking a shot at
i i have a feeling they've gotten to the
point where
they've had enough of that and they're
just ready to move forward and
showing up i think is the ticket to them
deciding to move on but mike
if if the packers knew this then why not
do it at draft
on at the draft you have a lot of teams
that come in to play more options here i
i don't understand
you're going to limit the market for
aaron rodgers
well look i agree with you completely
and i think they do get more for him
if they wait until after the season
you're going to have eight nine 10 teams
that are deciding
to move on from their current
quarterbacks and and that makes sense
but i'm just talking about the day in
and day out reality
of aaron rodgers back and aaron rodgers
in green bay and aaron rodgers
taking verbal shots at brian gudykoon
mark murphy whoever he can't help
himself
at some point he's going to break you
can see it the wheels spin in his head
he tries to resist at some point he's
going to say something and as
as sims and i have said on pft live if
you're mark murphy or brian gudekunst
don't go anywhere near the practice
field without a helmet on
and two cups because you're gonna get
the the walking boss treatment was the
walking boss the one that
that burt reynolds threw the football
and adam sandler did the same thing
right into the
you know yeah right into the sensitive
area if you're good coonster murphy
steer clear of aaron rodgers with the
football issue why doesn't rogers just
say
trade me i i think he enjoys
whether it's yeah
like if his end game is to get traded
then why didn't you jump on this two
months ago
dan i've been saying that since the
moment he activated
this story the first day of the draft
i've got to be looking at the rams and
going
i should be the starting quarterback for
the rams
yes right and or the 49ers yeah or the
49ers the team that he wanted to go to
as the first pick in the 2005 draft he
wanted to go to the 49ers and and that's
really what started this
it was my my friend paul allen of kfan
reporting
that the 49ers made a run at aaron
rodgers
that all hit the day of the draft and
dan look i think that it was all
calculated and strategic and this was
his payback
because the packers turned his life
upside down draft day 2020
draft day 2021 he's going to turn their
life upside down i think it was all
planned it worked to perfection because
look at what we've been talking about
for the last three and a half months
desean watson any chance he shows up
next week can he show up next week
well he can because no one has said from
the league whether or not he's going to
be on
paid leave and i've been saying for
weeks now that the league has had a
chance to conduct its preliminary
investigation into these 22
civil lawsuits and decide yes or no up
or down
desean watson gets put on the
commissioner exempt list
in 2021 and i think the right thing to
do in the fair thing to do is for the
league to tell the texans
watson and anyone else out there who may
want to trade for him
what his status is and not play this
guessing game and you'll find out
when we put him on the commissioner
exemplist that's what the league
typically does they won't tell you in
advance
because if he's not going to be put on
the commissioner exemplist i think the
chances of him traded
even with the pending lawsuits increases
dramatically whether it's the eagles the
dolphins the broncos
i think one of those three teams make a
run at him if the league says
we're not putting him on the
commissioner exempt list is the nfl
investigating the buccaneers for the tom
brady injury or hiding the injury
never putting him on the injured list i
think i played the full season with a
torn mcl
that required surgery promptly after the
super bowl and he never showed up on the
injury report once with a knee problem
and if i asked the league
as evidences come out after the fact
about the severity of the knee injury
do you have a comment on this did they
violate the injury report and the league
has consistently said
no comment and dan i think based on
dealing with the league for the last 20
years
if there was no violation they would say
so no comment to me implies
that the buccaneers did something here
they shouldn't have done they knew
about the knee even if tom brady had his
own
separate setup where he got all of his
treatment from alex guerrero and company
and the trainers for the buccaneers
never knew about the knee there's no way
the coaching staff
didn't know that you know he's trying to
protect his left knee don't expect me to
roll out don't expect me to do this
i'm i i'm doing three step five step
drop and i'm getting rid of the football
as quickly as possible
because my knees got one hit and i take
that one hit
and there goes the acl again and we're
done and that's why they hit it
that's the problem with transparency for
gambling purposes
and the strategy of keeping your your
injured guys healthy
you don't want to paint a target on the
injured body part that's why the
buccaneers never disclosed it
okay but what information
the gamblers you know with total
transparency
they want to know this stuff now
are they is the league obligated to give
gamblers this much information a
microphone
here's the problem dan as i try to do
some my microphone has a torn mcl
apparently um
if there is not full transparency
then that means there is inside
information to be had
which creates an incentive for the
gamblers to try to find it
which means certain people who have the
inside information are going to be
worked on
to share the inside information and this
is the kind of thing
that can spiral out of control for the
nfl i've had it
compared to inside information with with
publicly traded companies
non-material public or non-material
private information
that becomes known to certain people who
go buy and sell stocks
with that information you don't want
there to be inside information
that creates a potential for corruption
that creates a potential for
all sorts of infiltration by gambling
interests and the league needs to be
concerned about it
because the wrong scandal at the wrong
time
means congress gets involved maybe
creates an agency to oversee all
professional sports because gambling
is legalized sea to shining sea and at
some point
there's going to be an ambitious
prosecutor that has jurisdiction over
one of these teams
that maybe has people there who have
done things they shouldn't have done
next thing you know a grand is convened
next thing you know people get indicted
i think the league needs to work hard
to avoid that kind of outcome that's why
this brady thing is important
whoever knows the truth about injuries
has
uh the power to misuse that information
and create problems for the league
thank you mike as always have a great
week all right dan see you pal
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host you can see that show on peacock
preceding hours we'll take a break
our best and worst of the weekend we're
back after this